so the thing we're doing here at
Facebook is we partnered up with
facebook or a Super Mario maker facebook
hackathon for two days what that meant
was we invited employees engineers
designers from Facebook to come check
out Super Mario maker for two days make
their own course and at the end of that
kind of crown one course the grand prize
winner who we're going to give the
opportunity to kind of feature as the
Facebook course that represents the
entire company so what we were looking
at when we were judging levels was
actually a number of factors you know
Nintendo we really value fun surprise
creativity we're on the Facebook side
they're looking at like open honesty
moving very fast breaking things which
is great because Super Mario maker lets
you do things you can never do in a
Mario game before so as we were playing
these courses it was both like a delight
and also a little bit difficult because
of the volume of amazing courses kind of
whittling it down to just a few and even
one was the most difficult task of the
day I think
what I really liked about ship loved and
thought it deserved to win was really
the intricate amount of detail that went
into creating every interaction there
were a lot of puzzle like elements that
felt you know when you when you came
across a flop that activated a superstar
or you came across a group of red Koopa
shell that you might have to grab a
fireball and then throw flames out at
them with yoshi was just really
satisfying and the level just made you
smile the whole way through there were
challenging moments but it never felt
unfair and it always felt rewarding